[Music]
the first round this legal battle
between Meghan and the men on Sunday and
a victory for the newspaper after Judge
Mr Justice war be agreed to remove
certain parts of the Duchess's case
associated newspapers objected to three
aspects of the Duchess's case the
allegation that the newspaper acted
dishonestly the allegation that it had
deliberately dug up or stirred a
conflict between the Duchess and her
father and the allegation that it had an
agenda of publishing intrusive or
offensive stories about her in a summary
the judge found the allegations were
impermissibly vague and lacking in
particulars in relation to claims that
associated newspapers had in some ways
stirred up the conflict between the
Duchess and her father and that much
more detail would be required to enable
the pleaded claims to be fully
understood and dealt with in relation to
claims that the publisher had an obvious
agenda of publishing intrusive or
offensive stories Meghan is suing the
paper for publishing sections of a
letter that she wrote to her father in
case that her lawyers insists still
stands the extremes to which the Mail on
Sunday used distortive manipulative and
dishonest tactics to target the duchess
of sussex have been put on full display
whilst the judge recognizes that there
is a claim for breach of privacy and
copyright we surprised to see that his
ruling suggests that dishonest behavior
is not relevant we feel that honesty and
integrity are the core of what matters
the fact that the Duchess is legal team
been told that two of their key
arguments have to be struck out of this
case could be seen as a setback but
they're bullish statement shows that
Meghan and Harry have no intention of
backing down on this one as they follow
every step of this case from their new
home in America the couple are getting
used to new ways of living and working
video calling back to the UK to help
their charities as public opinion about
them continues to be split
at the time of the Cova to crisis and
the effect on people in Britain and
around the world the loss of life it
seems rather self-indulgent and and I
just think that they're in danger of
alienating support for this first legal
hearing may not have gone their way but
they are convinced they still have a
case and believe the mail on Sunday must
be held to account as we still wait for
a trial date to be set we an on Mills
Sky News in central London